بعد سخريه من عم بايدن وترشحي لرئاسه
مجددا سهام الجمهوريين تتوجه الى نائبته
اليوم او من باتت توصف بوظته المحتمله حيث
يسخر الجمهوريون ومنتقدون البيت الابيض من
كمال هاريس لترشحها مجددا الى جانب رئيس
جو بايدن في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره
في نوفمبر 202
رئيسه للبلاد لا سيما بايدن تجاوز عتبه
الثمانين من عمره السفيره الامريكيه
السابقه لدى الامم المتحده نيكي هيلي
اوضحت ان تصويت لبايدن يعني على ارض
الواقع الاعتماد على هاريس كرئيسه ووصفت
فكره بلو بايدن السته وثمانين عاما حين
نهايه ولايته انفاز بالامر غير المحتمل
فيما ذهب جمهوريون اخرون كاسنتور كروز الى
تشكيك بقدره كمالها على مواجهه رؤساء
كبوتين او نظريه الصيني ان صعدت لرئاسه
فجاه اضافه منتقدوه هاريس وبينهم
ديمقراطيون ان الوريثه المحتمله لبايدن
غير مستعده للمستقبل اداره البلاد وقد لا
تنال قضاياها استحسان الناخبين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات